évasion
[Musique]
je tiens mes promesses et donc je tiens
cette conférence de presse pourtant je
me demande vraiment vous pouvez en
attendre
que pourrais je dire de plus que ce qui
a déjà été amplement commentées depuis
le placement en garde à vue deux jeunes
acteurs d'aval toro notamment par ses
deux avocats
vous saviez donc avec deux juges
d'instruction ne soit saisie qui
seraient mises en examen et vous savez
désormais quoi puisqu'il a une qui fait
très rapidement et à part ces conseils
de l'existence d'éléments accablants à
son encontre
l'objectivité qui doit présider ou comme
ni d'autres coureurs de la république
n'aurait pas permis que j'utilise moi
même
cet adjectif mais puisqu'il est tout est
dit donne pas vraiment car les pilotes
de cette affaire qui a suscité un émoi
considérable dans la france entière et à
gré où le retentissement du meurtre puis
du placement en garde à vue deux jeunes
attendent
haïti est et sera considérable
il est les pilotes c'est le seul et
unique fruit d'un travail d'un kurt
absolument exemplaire remarquablement
conduit par la cellule composée des
gendarmes de la section des recherches
de besançon du groupement de gendarmerie
départementale de haute saône et du mans
sous l'autorité du juge d'instruction en
charge de l'information judiciaire et ce
malgré la pression sociale et médiatique
très forte
malgré des éléments de l'enquète qui
aurait dû rester secret mais qui ont été
relayés par la presse
heureusement suffisamment tardivement
pour ne pas l'entraver enquête qui a
permis après que les gendarmes est exclu
toutes les autres pistes et toutes les
autres hypothèses possibles celle d'une
mort accidentelle qui a été rapidement
écartée celle d'un rôdeur d'un prédateur
celle d'un amant ou une maîtresse ou
d'un proche
cette enquête a permis de réunir un
nombre suffisamment important d'éléments
objectifs qui ont pu conduire à
l'interpellation de jeunes attendent
aval à sa présentation devant le juge
d'instruction à sa mise en examen pour
meurtre sur conjoint en courant la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité et aux
réquisitions de placement en détention
provisoire que je viens de prendre sans
que monsieur d'aval net émis aucune
observation est que ces conseils n'est
pas plaider simplement corps présent ces
éléments qui ont permis cette
interpellation
thien tho témoignages recueillis à
l'exploitation et l'examen minutieux de
son véhicule de fonction de l'endroit où
a été retrouvé le corps d'alicia d'aval
aux incohérences également existant
entre les déclarations initiales du mise
en examen et la reconstitution complète
de son emploi du temps le matin du 28
octobre éléments qui je le précise était
suffisamment probants pour en tout état
de cause
résister aux dénégations du mise en
examen qui ont été effectivement
développé longuement par ses soins au
cours de ses différentes auditions mais
sur lesquelles il est revenu à la toute
fin de sa de sa garde à vue
l'anc est évidemment se poursuit sur
commission rogatoire puisque tous les
éléments évidemment aussi n'ont pas été
exploités complètement
je leur ai juste donné la parole de
petites minutes où vous colonel puisque
vous souhaitiez dire un mot sur sur le
travail qui a été effectué par les
gendarmes mais monsieur de changer de
cassation
il a beaucoup été question aujourd'hui
de preuves scientifiques ces matériels
vous avez entendu parler de traces de
pneumatiques de prélèvement sur un corps
de morceaux de tissus lorsqu'on a
affaire à un crime sans témoins ces
éléments sont décisifs et ils l'ont été
ils ont été recueillis au prix d'un
engagement de moyens exceptionnels
tout d'abord dans la phase initiale le
corps a été retrouvé en 48 heures après
que 400 gendarmes et ratissé
minutieusement 1 million de mètres
carrés de végétation dense et 9
kilomètres carrés de prairie avec des
hélicoptères et des drones des maîtres
de chiens et des plongeurs ont trouvé
encore dans un délai aussi bref est une
garantie pour la préservation de traces
et indices qui s'avèreront et qui se
sont avérés déterminants
deuxièmement ces éléments ont été
recueillis ils ont pu l'être grâce à
l'engagement immédiat sur les non pas la
scène de crime mais la scène de
découverte du cadavre de trois
techniciens en identification criminelle
avec leurs laboratoires qui ont
conditionné prélevés et envoyés en
laboratoire central
tous les éléments qui aujourd'hui ont
contribué de façon déterminante à
la manifestation la début de vérité
et troisièmement enfin comme ça et de
vient d'être dit la constitution d'une
cellule d'enquêté multidisciplinaire et
interservices qui a conjugué des moyens
issus de la haute saône enquêteurs qui
connaissent le terrain avec des
enquêteurs issus de besançon qui
apportent des expertises complémentaires
et les moyens d' expertise nationaux au
travers des laboratoires centraux au
total ce sont près de 500 gendarmes
issus de huit départements qui ont
concouru à cette affaire pour mettre à
disposition de la justice et de la
vérité
l'ensemble de leurs moyens et leur
énergie je voudrais simplement leur
rendre hommage
[Musique]
bien est-ce que vous avez des questions
à poser
d'abord je rentrerai pas dans les
détails de ces auditions je crois que ça
a été suffisamment fait par les conseils
de jeunes attendent à mal et je vais pas
en rajouter de ce côté là donc pour le
moment
vous savez ce qu'il en est de ces
déclarations au regard de celles qui
vous ont été faites par les avocats moi
je ne rajouterai rien de plus
dans l'immédiat
ça n'a pas été évoquée en tout cas
la mise en examen elle elle va elle va
coller effectivement aux éléments
d'enquêté qu'on a recueilli elle va
coller aussi aux déclarations qui ont
été effectués même si elle ne le col pas
complètement aux dernières déclarations
qui ont pu être effectués par jonathan
navale et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle une requalification qui a été
fait par le juge d'instruction à la
demande du parquet de meurtre sur
conjoint
la préméditation n'a pas été retenue
mais c'est la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité est encourue la même manière
que pour les fascine
ce sont ces explications il explique
effectivement un comportement de son de
son épouse qui était à nos comportements
parfois un peu particulier peut-être au
regard des médicaments ça ça fait encore
partie des éléments que les gendarmes et
le juge d'instruction sans doute ou
devons aller un peu plus loin sur ce sûr
c'est sur ce comportement je ne vous
dirai pas spécialement ce que sont ces
médicaments sont des médicaments ça fait
partie de ce parti de l'enquète ça n'a
guère d'intérêt
ce qui permet de retenir la
qualification de meurtre se sont toutes
les constatations qui ont été effectuées
par les services de gendarmerie c'est
effectivement la mort par strangulation
il ya encore par rapport on est qu'à
trois mois delà de la découverte du
corps c'est à dire que tout ça est allé
à la fois sûrement trop lentement pour
vous mais mais très vite et très
complètement et je le répète de façon
absolument exemplaire traîne en matière
d' enquêtes ça aboutit effectivement à à
[Musique]
à ce que à ce que à ce que je me suis
une autre question pourquoi pas les
coups mortels et pourquoi est morte donc
l'ensemble des explications excusez moi
je suis un peu fatigué l'ensemble de ces
explications ont abouti effectivement de
ces de ces éléments d'enquêté en tout
cas on aboutit effectivement à des
éléments suffisants pour imaginer que la
mort a été donnée volontairement et non
pas en tout cas
ac actuellement accidentellement
voilà l'avocat ils l'exposent ce qu'il a
envie d'exposer il évoque ce qui sera
effectivement ses moyens de défense
je n'ai rien à en dire je n'ai rien à en
dire pour le moment c'est jonathan
d'aval qui a été placé en garde à vue
qui a été présenté devant un juge
d'instruction et on n'a aucun élément
dans l'immédiat en tout cas qui
permettent d'évoquer une quelconque
complicité à par hypothèse oui et elle
est habillée en joggeuse vous supposez
tout ce que vous voulez supposée
que les coups mortels par deux les coûts
mais dans l'immédiat quand on quand on
va quand on va choisir une qualification
on va choisir toujours la qualification
par hypothèse la plus haute est celle
qui correspond le mieux en tout cas est
ce que les éléments de l'enquète ont
permis d'établir dans l'immédiat une
mort par par asphyxie puisque c'est le
cas en ce qui concerne alexiane amal est
pour moi un meurtre qui a été commis par
le conjoint ses hôtes c'est également la
conclusion du juge d'instruction
non non témoignage du bénin sera
totalement insuffisant c'est un ensemble
c'est qu'on l'a rappelé un ensemble
d'éléments probants qui ont été
recueillies qui sont des éléments
objectifs qui ont été recueillis par
cette cellule d'enquêté qui ont tous
convergé à un moment donné et après
effectivement que toutes les hypothèses
et pu être exclue par les enquêteurs
on n'a pas travaillé spécifiquement ils
n'ont pas travaillé spécifiquement sur
l'hypothèse de delà du meurtre par le
conjoint ils ont déjà évacué toutes les
autres hypothèses possibles et
l'ensemble des éléments qui ont été
recueillis convergeaient et ont convergé
vers effectivement cette mise en cause
leur odeur le rôdeur le prédateur le
rôdeur et prédateurs n'a pas été
spécialement rapidement écartée c'est à
dire que le theule le moi j'ai été au
parquet j'ai reçu un certain nombre
d'informations qui provenaient d'autres
parquet relatives à des personnes
dangereuses qui étaient des qui était
connu pour des agressions sexuelles et
qui aurait pu se trouver sur les lieux
toutes ces hypothèses là ont été évacués
par les services de gendarmerie et il y
en a eu plusieurs
comment des centaines de signalements
alors exactement
il ya de nombreux témoins qui qui qui
qui sont venus expliquer un certain
nombre de choses comme d'habitude
d'ailleurs quand on a des affaires
extrêmement médiatisé et tout ça a été
prise au sérieux systématiquement par
les enquêteurs tout a été prise au
sérieux tout a été écartée et dans le
même temps puisque le travail c'est fait
évidemment dans le même temps et on
recueille à la fois les et les éléments
par des expertises qui ont été
sollicités par des recoupements qui ont
été faits par la sepa authority fait par
la cellule d'enquêté et dans le même
temps toutes les hypothèses étaient
étaient évacués le drap qui recouvrait
le drap qui recouvrait le corps le
packing recouvrait pour partie en tout
cas le port de gaza était un élément
central ont effectivement c'était un
élément central
on imaginait en effet en effet mal un
rôdeur ou un prédateur qui la
rencontrent par hasard alors qu'elle
fait son jogging qui a un drap dans son
dans sa voiture et qui voit là donc ça
ça fait partie aussi des éléments qui
ont permis d'écarter les autres
hypothèses faut le demander à ses
avocats
moi je ne suis pas là pour parler à la
passe de jonathan d'amal je pense qu'il
a des voix pour ça et qui s'exprime
largement suffisamment
on n'a pas à rentrer dans des nappes à
rentrer dans des éléments qui sont des
éléments de l'enquète qui font partie
effectivement dû se faire d'instruction
d'étude de la voiture a été déterminante
aussi bien sur l'ensemble de ces
éléments a convergé vers jonathan navale
c'est l'ensemble de ces éléments c'est
comme je les dis le travail qui a été
effectué et non pas sur la peut-être pas
sur la scène de crime parce que c'est
sans doute pas là que le crime a été
commis
et maintenant on le sait à peu près mais
en tout cas sur ce qui a été découvert
le travail qui a été effectué en effet
sur la téléphonie qui a été effectuée
sur le véhicule automobile
c'est tous ces éléments là qui sont je
le répète des éléments totalement
objectif totalement d'objectifs et qui
ont recoupé effectivement les différents
témoignages qui ont été recueillies et
témoignages dont certains étaient
également tout à fait essentiel dont on
a pas de zones d'ombré enfin il ya plus
de zones d'ombré particulière dans s'il
y en avait avant
maintenant en tout cas il y en a
beaucoup moins
ça ça fait partie des déclaration qu'il
fera devant le juge d'instruction et qui
seront effectivement ensuite exploitées
peut-être dans le cadre de la commission
rogatoire pour s'assurer que tous les
éléments nécessaires à la formation ils
sont donc pour le moment on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas en parler
exc
c'est vraisemblablement une dispute
conjugale
alors c'est vraisemblablement une
dispute conjugale on reste toujours il
faut toujours rester
voilà il faut faire toujours un peu
attention c'est reste toujours des
hypothèses
donc la formation de judiciaire n'est
pas terminée que tous les éléments n'ont
pas été recueillies
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas affirmer
on affirmera si un jour effectivement
jonathan d'aval comparaît devant une
cour d'assises
mais avant ça reste toujours des
hypothèses que l'on travaille et qui
sont toujours travaillé par le juge
d'instruction par les enquêteurs
vraisemblablement semblablement tué
effectivement dans la nuit
avant l'avant le
avant que souhaite avant tout cas que
soit déclaré sa disparition
je rentre pas dans des considérations
aussi précise ça fait partie
effectivement une enquête j'ai pas elle
commenté
c'est qu'à un moment donné les
enquêteurs sont arrivés à un travail qui
pour eux est abouti c'est pas il n'y a
pas eu un top départ il n'y a pas eu un
choix particulier qui a été effectué il
ya un moment donné d'une enquête mais le
fait qu'on est arrivé effectivement à ce
que tous les éléments nécessaires et
probant soient réunies pour aboutir à
l'interpellation et au placement en
garde à vue
c'est tout voilà ça n'a été choisi pour
rien d'autre que pour cette raison là
bien
ce ne sont pas des circonstances
aggravantes légal ça peut être des
circonstances qui peuvent être prises en
compte comme étant à aggravantes
voilà par un jury voilà mais ça ne ce
n'est pas une circonstance aggravante en
tout cas également la seule circonstance
aggravante qu'on a retenue et qui suffit
qui se suffit à elle-même puisque ça
fait encourir la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
c'est le fait de donner la mort à son
conjoint non ça suffit le dire ce qui
s'est passé avant et après et pendant
ça fait partie de cette race est parti
du meurtre ou ça fait partie des
ça fait partie du contexte qu'il soit
postérieur antérieures ça devient
d'assassinât postérieur ce sera pris en
compte mais ça n'est pas une
circonstance aggravante
voilà je voulais revenir simplement sur
le déroulement de l'enquêté sur les
trois mois parce que ça a été
relativement longue puisque suite donc
effectivement l enquête pour disparition
inquiétante qui avait avait été ouverte
puis pour découverte de cadavre il ya
une information qui judiciaire qui a été
ouverte et à la suite de laquelle une
cellule d'enquêté a été montée donc
celle une enquête composée de douze
enquêteurs tus des des gens des
analystes criminels qui a travaillé à
temps complet sur ce dossier et qui
effectivement elle était composée de
militaires de la section de recherches
du groupement de gendarmerie
départementale de haute saône mais
également du doubs puisque ils étaient
ils habitent et valider le fait qu' il
fallait mettre des moyens en personnel
et en matériel de manière à pouvoir
résoudre cette affaire au plus le plus
rapidement possible donc par une
subsidiarité d'unités territoriales et
d'unités de recherche dédié à la police
judiciaire
un travail considérable a été abattu en
l'espace de trois mois avec une synergie
parfaite entre les différents enquêteurs
qui a permis d'éliminer successivement
les différentes hypothèses envisagées
notamment que ce soit l' accident
maquillé d'une part un rôdeur ou un
délinquant sexuel du coin ou d'une zone
plus éloignée et également la piste dans
l'environnement familial qui soit sous
forme d'un amant d'une maîtresse via une
liaison ou dans l'environnement familial
ou là intervient effectivement le mari
par les moyens de police technique et
scientifique qui ont été déployés via
notre l'abolir cgn à pontoise mais
également en direction d'autres labos il
a été mis à jour des éléments qui sont
incriminant véhicules notamment au
niveau du véhicules nemo des témoignages
des éléments résultant de la police
technique et scientifique
des anomalies dans les emplois du temps
et des constatations également lors des
perquisitions
et tous ces éléments là pour verger vers
une même hypothèse la perquisition
venant effectivement en dernier lieu et
le 29 janvier donc ça a permis de
l'interpellation puisqu'il fallait il
fallait traiter la dernière hypothèse
avec tous les éléments qui convergeaient
ça a permis l'interpellation de jonathan
johnattan d'aval à la suite de poids et
effectivement ils se retrouvaient placé
en garde à vue par des enquêteurs mais
également par des spécialistes des des
parts du département des sciences du
comportement et ce qui a permis
d'aboutir en fait aux aveux aux aveux
circonstanciés en fin d'après midi
voilà voilà tout ce que je voulais dire
pour le travail de là c'est une enquête
on est on est dans les spécialités
d'ordre psychologiques et psychiatriques
sont capables de décrypter des
comportements et qui peuvent apporter
une aide aux enquêteurs chargés des
gardes à vue
ils ne lisent pas les conférences de
presse
c'est complètement différent évidemment
une analyse plus les scènes de crime
voilà mais ils sont pas et c'est pas les
comportementaliste qu'on peut voir au
canada par exemple et donc ce n'est pas
ça n'est pas ce qui aurait pu être
intéressant en effet l'analyse de
comportement de jonathan d'aval
lorsqu'il a été interviewé lorsqu'il a
fait un certain nombre de choses
non c'est pas comme ça qu'il travaille
chez nous en tout cas et c'est pas ce ne
sont pas des experts c'est simplement
des des z os pour les enquêteurs elle a
eu des bons résultats
de bons résultats qui seront
effectivement qu'ils sont et et frais
effectifs
j'ai simplement j'ai simplement dit que
c'était des résultats qui était oui mais
des écoutes je n'ai pas à vous répondre
sur le fond et sur est sûr et ce qui
fait partie des enquêtes
je suis resté très générales dans ma
réponse
non non je rentre pas dans les détails
des commissions rogatoires de quoi que
ce soit sur le profil psychologique
au début tous en larmes au moment où la
marche bien en ce moment c'est ce sont
les expertises qui double j'espère en
tout cas et pour la lumière sur cette
personnalité qui paraît effectivement un
complexe on a tout vu je veux dire tout
est marquant c'est c'est vrai que c'est
marquant c'est sûr que c'est marquant
est que je le dis ça ça suscitera sans
doute un émoi considérable à gré où
beaucoup de personnes s'étaient
mobilisées pour le soutenir et qui
doivent se trouvait évidemment
aujourd'hui un peu trahi
on n'a pas à rentrer non plus on n'a pas
à rentrer non plus la dansé dansé dansé
et les mémés tout est intéressant le
problème c'est que c'est que c'est que
tout est protégé par le secret de
l'enquêté qui on ne peut pas rentrer
dans des détails qui qui voilà qui n'ont
pas d'intérêt dans le cadre d'une
conférence de presse ça se passe comme
ça
alors quand on est tant qu'acteur on est
on est d'abord un professionnel on
n'entre absolument pas dans ces
considérations et c'est parce qu'on
n'entre pas dans ces considérations là
qu'on est un bon enquêteur
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas faut pas se
tromper ça veut dire qu'on recueille le
travail n'est pas de dire je pars d'une
hypothèse je fait en sorte de la montée
est pourvu que je me trompe pas c'est
absolument pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne comme je vous
le dis on voit toutes les hypothèses on
les travaille tout on recueille tous les
éléments ont fait toutes les les
tous les examens qui sont possibles on
recueille tous les témoignages
ensuite aux voies vers où ça converge et
à ce moment là on travaille sur la
personne qui est mise en cause de façon
un peu plus importante
à partir du moment où jonathan d'aval a
été interpellé avec l'aval évidemment du
juge d'instruction sous l'autorité
duquel de laquelle la cellule
travaillait c'est qu'il existait des
éléments suffisamment probants pour son
placement en garde à vue puis ensuite
pour sa présentation et sa mise en
examen
je n'en sais rien il a ils ont également
un avocat qui a pu s'exprimer sur sur
sur ça on va pas je veux pas m'exprimer
à la place des partis c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
il fait pas moi qui disais voilà
de la même manière on va pas rentrer
dans le détail de la manière de la façon
dont tout cela s'est déroulé ça s'est
déroulé comme ça ça s'est terminé
effectivement part par des aveux
voilà c'est mieux c'est mieux pour nous
même si ça n'était pas indispensable
voilà oui ceci avec les avocats
mais il n'y a pas eu d'opération
particulière qui on est et qui ont été
présentés donc c'est un placement en
détention provisoire
c'est l'accalmie